and the American music award goes to
Chris Brown
Now Chris Brown is not here tonight so
I'm accepting this award on his behalf
excuse me ciao chill out Kelly Rowland
tells the audience to chill out after
Chris Brown's win at the American Music
Awards you never know what to expect
yeah a pretty unexpected moment as the
singer presented the award for favorite
male R B artist where Chris was up
against Brent faiyaz gibeon lucky day
and the weekend and the American music
award goes to
Chris Brown but after reading Chris's
name the announcement was met with booze
and Kelly she wasn't here for it and
came to his defense
Now Chris Brown is not here tonight so
I'm accepting this award on his behalf
excuse me ciao chill out but I want to
tell Chris thank you so much for making
great r b music and I want to tell him
thank you for being an incredible
performer I'll take this award bring it
to you I love you congratulations
Chris's ama's win comes after a bit of
controversy just days before the show
the singer claimed they canceled his
performance last minute he posted this
video from a rehearsal and wrote in the
caption would have been the AMA
performance but they canceled me for
reasons unknown
foreign
[Music]
the clip also shows Chris was set to pay
tribute to the late Michael Jackson
specifically the Thriller album which
recently celebrated its 40th anniversary
[Music]
but as Kelly explained to E.T ahead of
the show always expect the unexpected
you know what I I love the fact that at
the amas it's very spontaneous you never
know what to expect and um you know
that's what I'm most excited about
tonight I'm excited about seeing all
these artists and how they plan on
expressing themselves and you know it's
really exciting
foreign